bonjour alors je vous remercie d'abord
de m'avoir invité à venir vous parler
d'eux d autres mondes là vous avez
entendu parler de beaucoup de choses sur
terre mais le vent un peu le regard vers
le ciel et je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui des exoplanètes ou planètes
extrasolaires c'est à dire les planètes
qui tournent autour des toiles qui ne
sont pas le soleil donc ces planètes
extrasolaires c'est en quelque sorte les
nouveaux mondes que l'astronome est en
train de découvrir aujourd'hui c'est un
peu comme aujourd'hui l'époque
contemporaine
aujourd'hui pour l'astronome c'est un
peu comme ya 500 ans quand christophe
colomb découvre l amérique et bien
l'astrophysicien aujourd'hui découvre un
nouveau monde et c'est ce que je vais
vous décrire maintenant alors je vais
vous décrire maintenant vous allez me
dire voilà c'est ta science fiction l'on
va partir dans star wars etc
non non c'est vraiment la recherche
contemporaine et c'est pas uniquement la
recherche d'objets de planète c'est
aussi la compréhension de ce que sont
ces objets est-ce qu'ils sont habitables
ce que la vie peuvent s'y développer
et même éventuellement est ce que la vie
s'y est développée et ultime mans est ce
que la vie intelligente s'est développée
ce sont des questions que nous nous
posons aujourd'hui dans la recherche
contemporaine
alors dire vous vous le savez peut-être
déjà un peu si vous avez ouvert vos
journaux il ya deux trois semaines
vous avez entendu parler de la
découverte de trois planètes
potentiellement habitables comme c'était
titré dans le figaro alors on avait
effectivement très découvert récemment
trois planètes
je vous cache pas que cette découverte a
été légérement survendu en réalité bon
la description qui en a été fait était
peut-être un petit peu exagéré mais je
vais revenir sur ce point un peu plus
tard mais cette question des planètes
extrasolaires ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
on y répond aujourd'hui mais elle est
posée depuis très très longtemps depuis
plusieurs siècles
depuis qu'on a réalisé
que le soleil notre soleil
on avait une image ici n'est rien
d'autre qu'une étoile mais une étoile
tout à fait ordinaire c'est pas une
étoile plus petit ou plus grosse que les
autres plus chaudes plus froide avec
plus riches en métal ou non c'est une
étoile vraiment banal tout à fait
ordinaire parmi les étoiles de la
galaxie
et quand on a réalisé ça il ya plusieurs
siècles on se pose on se pose
immédiatement tous vous poser
immédiatement la question mais si le
soleil est une étoile parmi les étoiles
qui peuplent le ciel est ce que ces
autres étoiles comme celle ci que je
montre là a aussi est ce que ces autres
étoiles ont aussi des planètes qui
tournent autour d'un cette question est
posée depuis des siècles et pour la
plupart d'entre vous quand vous êtes
allés à l'école nous a sans doute appris
qu'il y avait neuf aux huit planètes que
autour du soleil et c'est tout c'est la
seule chose qu'on connaissait jusqu'à il
ya une vingtaine d'années pourquoi parce
que c'est très difficile de détecter ces
planètes
elles sont très très faible très proches
de leur étoile lors étoiles est très
brillante et donc il est très difficile
de détecter la lumière de cette planète
et même je vais peut-être vous décevoir
mais je vais vous montrer aucune image
de ces planètes aujourd'hui nous n'avons
à quelques exceptions près pas du tout
d'imagerie rôle quand je dis une image
juste un petit point lumineux à côté
d'une tâche très brillante
donc nous n'avons pas d'image parce que
c'est difficile de quasi impossible avec
technologie actuelle d'avoir une image
d'une exoplanète
donc il faut utiliser notre intelligence
pour détecter ces planètes et c'est ce
que je vais vous décrire je vous dire qu
rires comment on a pu détecter ces
nouveaux mondes et puis évidemment si
vous voulez chercher des planètes on
cherche tous une planète qui
éventuellement ressemblerait à la terre
on aurait trouvé la soeur jumelle de la
terre
aujourd'hui on en est pas encore là mais
on a découvert des planètes qui
ressemble un peu à la terreur plutôt des
soeurs jumelles
j'ai plutôt envie de les appeler les
cousines de la terre et je vous montrais
une de ses cousines et enfin
on aimerait bien les caractériser en
savoir plus sur leur contenu et donc on
est capable aujourd'hui je vais vous le
montrez on est capable de détecter le
contenu de l'atmosphère de ces planètes
dont vous voyez des planètes qu'on l'a
même pas vu on est capable de voix de
savoir ne pas devoir mais de savoir quel
est leur contenu je vais vous expliquer
comment on fait ça alors tout d'abord
comment on les détecte alors on peut pas
les voir
donc il va falloir utiliser des méthodes
que l'on appel indirect
la première méthode qu'on a utilisé ses
la détection du mouvement de l'étoile
parce que je vais peut-être même dit par
abus de langage la planète tourne autour
de son étoile en réalité c'est pas
exactement ça ce qui se passe c'est que
l'ensemble planètes étoiles tournent
autour de son centre de gravité est la
conséquence de ça c'est que quand la
planète tourne autour d'un bal voyez je
fais la bible ancien chercheur commence
quand la planète tourne autour du centre
de gravité du système planètes étoiles
là les toiles sont aussi une autre façon
de le dire c'est là elle tourner parce
qu'il ya la gravité l'attraction
gravitationnelle
action réaction là l'étoile attire la
planète la planète entière les toiles et
donc la planète fait bouger les toiles
si on est capable de détecter ce
mouvement de l'étoile par exemple on la
voit bouger en un an on se dit tiens
c'est quelque chose qui fait bouger les
toiles c'est une planète qui tourne en
un an autour de l'étoile et c'est ainsi
qu'on a découvert les premières planètes
je montre ici la courbe d'une planète de
déplacement d'une d'une étoile qui a
permis de détecter une des premières
planètes en 1995 à part michel mayor et
didier queloz à l'observatoire de haute
provence
il ya une autre technique qui a permis
les détecter énormément de ces planètes
c'est la méthode des transits alors là
cette fois ci on observe une étoile ou
la planète passe devant mais quand elle
passe devant bas le cache une petite
partie de la surface de l'étoile
donc on reçoit moins de lumière on
mesure la brillance de l'étoile en
fonction du temps et tout d'un coup on
la voit s'éteindre baisser un petit peu
s'éteindre un peu c'est ce qui est
représenté sur cette cour vous voyez
quand ce qu'on appelle une courbe de
lumière quand la planète passe devant
l'étoile est moins brillante et on a
détecté
un très grand nombre de planètes en
utilisant cette technique c'est la
technique qui étaient utilisés pour
détecter les trois planètes trappistes
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
alors là on mesure pas la masse la
première fois puisqu'on démesurée le
déplacement de l'étoile on mesure la
masse l'a cette fois ci on voit la
quantité de lumière caché par la planète
donc on mesure la taille de la planète
où son rayon alors ces techniques que
sont très efficaces et je vous disais il
ya une vingtaine d'années on connaissait
que huit planètes les huit planètes du
système solaire
aujourd'hui en mille ans en 2016 mais
bien nous connaissons plus de 3000
planète
il pleut des planètes pour reprendre
l'expression le titre du livre de mon
collègue fred vidal madjar et en fait on
connaît pas trois mille étoiles autour
desquels tour des planètes ne connais un
peu moins connaît à peu près de 2500
étoile autour desquels tour des planètes
parce que il ya des petits systèmes
multiples des planètes de pardon des
étoiles autour desquels tournent eux
plusieurs planètes
alors maintenant je vais pas voulu
décrire les 3400 3408 j'en serais bien
incapable et on m'a pas donné assez de
temps c'est bien dommage
la prochaine fois vous pour
l'organisation de ces conférences vous
préférez à 7 ans et je vous expliquerai
c'est 3408 planète nous contenter d'une
seule aujourd'hui une cousine de la
terre gliese 581c alors c'est une
planète dont la découverte a été
annoncée en avril 2007 et les propriétés
et eux vont sembler un peu exotique la
planète tournant 13 jours autour de son
étoile
je rappelle que mercure la planète la
plus proche mais 80 jours a tourné
autour du soleil
la 13 jours elle est très proche de son
étoile elle est 14 fois plus proche de
son étoile que le soleil
que la terre ne l'est du soleil que dire
oh là là doit faire chaud dedans
non parce qu'il ya un mais le mais c'est
que cette étoile est une étoile
faiblement brillante
c'est une naine rouge un peu comme
l'image qu'on a vu tout au début
donc c'est une étoile beaucoup moins
brillantes et grosso modo la différence
de distance entre eux
cette étoile et la planète par rapport
aux systèmes solitaire compense par la
baisse de fin la différence de distance
compense la différence de luminosité et
le résultat c'est que cette planète
reçoit à peu près autant d'énergie que
la terre en reçoit du soleil et la
température doit être assez proche que
la température qui règne à la surface de
la terre
et en plus il se trouve que c'est une
planète qui fait 5 fois la masse de la
terre
donc on se dit cinq fois la masse de la
terre c'est très très probablement une
planète solide rocheuses voyez on
s'enfonce pas dedans et donc on se dit
ben c'est pas mal c'est une planète
typiquement sur laquelle la vie pourrait
se développer à la surface alors en
réalité la seule chose qu'on connaisse
et c'est sa masse on connaît même pas ça
son rayon cette planète
alors on peut dessiner une vue d'artiste
jeudi on a pas d'image on peut dessiner
une vue d'artiste comme on imagine cette
planète et vous avez vu cette planète au
premier plan avec des deux autres
planètes parce que c'est un système
multi planétaire on connaît au moins
deux autres planètes et qui tourne
autour d'une étoile naine rouge
ça c'est ce qu'on peut dessiner si on
est un assez réaliste de ce qu'on
connaît de ce système mais je voulais
aussi vous raconter une histoire c'est
que en avril 2007 quand les astronomes
ont découvert cette planète ont ils ont
écrit leurs articles scientifiques
ils ont dit qu'ils ont dit au tien au
service de communication de leurs
laboratoires
moi ça serait bien qu'on en parle dans
les médias alors voilà ce qu'on savait
la personne qui s'occupe de faire le
communiqué de presse du oui mais pour
que ça fasse un peu de buzz quand même
va falloir que je dise vraiment il fait
la température et bien si si si c'est
solide ne peut y avoir de l'eau liquide
et on sait que le liquide c'est propice
à l'apparition de la vie
voilà donc il décrit sa dans le
communiqué de presse les journaux ont
reçu le communiqué de presse lundi ouais
c'est propre peut y avoir de l'eau
liquide
on va écrire qu'il ya de l'eau liquide
la vie petit développer oui voyez donc
voila et ont publié à la fin est vrai de
vrai le soir quand je suis rentré chez
moi
les annonces ont été faites dans les
journaux mon épouse m'a dit j'ai écouté
france info aujourd'hui et j'ai entendu
vous avez découvert une planète sur
lequel il y avait de l'eau liquide des
montagnes des arbres et peut-être même
des petits bonhommes qui se pratique qui
se déplace à la surface voilà comment
entre eux finalement une la découverte
d'une planète habitable
on est devenu une planète habitée donc
je vous invite à quand vous avez des
annonces publiées dans l'est dans les
journaux à prendre un peu de recul et
essayer de savoir qu'est ce qu'on s'est
vraiment qu'est ce qui est de l'ordre du
certains de l'ordre de l'hypothétique et
de leurs deux hyper poté et poétique
alors quand même que je veux pas vous
décourager trop et je dédie tout au
début que nous sommes capables de
détecter les atmosphères de ces planètes
comment on fait et bien ce qu'on fait
c'est que on analyse la lumière de
l'étoile
quand la planète passe devant l'étoile
quand la planète passe devant les toiles
je veux dire le cache un peu de la
lumière de l'étoile
mais il ya une partie de la lumière de
l'étoile qui traversent l'atmosphère de
la planète
donc si on analyse ses plumes hier on
est capable de détecter très faible
signature de cette atmosphère de cette
exoplanète et c'est ce qu'on fait c'est
ce que vous êtes capable de faire aussi
vous avez tous déjà vu l'atmosphère
d'une planète vue en transparence par la
lumière de son étoile
vous avez tous déjà vu ça elle pas venir
vous n'avez jamais regardé coucher de
soleil
bah oui quand vous regardez un coucher
de soleil le soleil est peu brillant il
est rouge parce que il ya l'absorption
de la lumière du soleil par l'atmosphère
de la terre
et quand vous regardez un coucher de
soleil rouge c'est la signature de la
diffusion rayleigh des molécules
d'oxygène et d'azoté donc vous en
regardant le coucher de soleil vous
voulez détecter fin déduire la présence
de l'atmosphère et même dvd
parti de sa composition en quelque sorte
merci exactement ce que l'on fait pour
les exoplanètes
on les observe quand le passent devant
leur étoile on est capable de détecter
un très grand nombre d'éléments et la
liste que j'ai dressé ici c'est pas une
liste c'est pas une wishing liste c'est
parce que j'aimerais détectée c'est ce
que nous détectons aujourd'hui dans les
atmosphères de ces deux planètes vous
voyez que dans l'ultraviolet on détecte
de l'hydrogène et l'oxygène l'hélium du
silicium dans le visible des aérosols du
sodium est très important dans
l'infrarouge nous détectons des
molécules du méthane de l'eau du
monoxyde de carbone et dioxyde de
carbone et donc nous sommes capables de
détecter des choses qui s'approche des
molécules de la vie nous savons qu'il
faut l'eau pour l'apparition de la vie
et donc c'est exactement ce que nous
essayons de faire aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment la science contemporaine nous
posons la question de comment détecter
la vie quelle est la signature de la
ville est une des réponses possibles se
trouve dans le diagramme suivant où vous
avez le spectre de trois planètes du
système solaire propre planète
tellurique vénus la terre et mars
et on voit que sur au pardon on voit que
sur vénus la terre et mars
il ya du dioxyde de carbone mais que
l'atmosphère de la terre elle toute
toute petite particularité c'est qu'il
ya pas que dioxyde de carbone il y à
aussi de l'eau est encore plus important
il ya des molécules d'oxygène et ces
molécules d'oxygène
elles sont produites par la vie la
molécule d'oxygène est détruite très
rapidement par des mécanismes
d'oxydation et donc si vous avez de
l'oxygène dans l'atmosphère d'une
planète c'est qu'il se passe quelque
chose de tout à fait extraordinaire
c'est donc un bio marqueur une signature
de la vie et c'est typiquement ce genre
de signatures que nous espérons détecter
prochainement dans les exoplanètes et
pour soi on imagine déjà les instruments
qui permettront de le faire par exemple
des flopées de satellites fa télescope
dans l'espace qui combinent leurs
lumières pour faire des analyses très
poussées des planètes de petite taille
qui ressemblerait à la terre
et bon alors aujourd'hui on n'est pas
encore là on en est pas encore à aller
là bas mais on va terminer cette
conférence par un petit voyage je vous
invite à faire le voyage
imaginons que nous sommes capables
d'aller là-bas de voir l'atmosphère de
cette planète d'eads dans la planète
nous voyons un ballon dans une
atmosphère une planète géante gazeuse
exoplanètes et j'ai fait pour vous le
calcul de caisse que nous verrions et
vous allez voir les couleurs du ciel
d'une exoplanète les vraies couleurs là
c'est pas une vie d'artiste c'est un
vrai calcul numérique et on va voir donc
le les couleurs d'un coucher des toiles
vue d'une exoplanète oublier le ciel est
très différente chez nous il est plutôt
pourpre et la planète qui se couche le
pardon le soleil qui se couche va
devenir plus tôt vers sion et et c'est
même plutôt vers à la fin
je vous remercie